hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week you know my favorite thing is
so we have a remote control to this
camera right and when we remote control
the camera so it doesn't shake right so
it doesn't do the right so it doesn't
shake right and what I've noticed is
that our our camera guy he will really
hit that record button with gusto in the
background so he like throws it down
like it's a baseball bat
and I don't know if it helps the camera
come on any faster but it's pretty funny
to watch all right this week we're
talking about cmmc control
ia.l2-3.5.11 obscure feedback of
authentication information whatever the
world obscure means I'm gonna have to
dictionary it while I play you this
awesome intro
[Music]
say hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all this cmmc
dfars and nist sp-800 171 compliance
stuff on top of an already colossal
workload well I've got great news for
you you found your home here in on-call
compliance Solutions we can help you
transform into your company's on-call
compliance Hero Let's jump into it cmmc
control ia.l
2-3.5.11 obscure feedback of
authentication information you know
sometimes I think to myself man they
probably could have worded these
controls a little bit better than this
but maybe they couldn't have maybe
obscure is an obscure word maybe I just
don't like the word obscure like I don't
like the word moist there's just
something weird about the word moist
like if you say it three times fast
it sounds weird
anyway obscure is kind of a weird word
that's where I'm going with this
if you went somewhere else
it's not my fault
what this control is really referring to
is when you are typing in your password
you should not just be able to see the
typed in password okay you should see
dots or asterisks or emojis or anything
but the password in case someone
is looking over your shoulder or through
a screen share
like some creepy tech support guy
I don't know any of those the idea is no
looky-loos should be able I should be
able to get these damn it ah but we're
not editing this tape because we don't
do that here on this channel way too
lazy for that
but lookie lose is a really funny word
from the 70s might have been the 60s I
don't know I wasn't born until the 80s
so I couldn't tell you but the idea is
no looky loose should be able to get
your passwords especially in systems
which contain cui now let's see what the
assessors are looking for on that one
uh uh well the good news is they're not
looking for much there's only one
assessment Point here determine if
authentication information is obscured
during the authentication process
duh all right implement it as
authentication information is entered it
is obscured by generic characters during
the authentication process and basically
this is another one of those sort of
demonstration controls you could write
the answer all you want and you will
right there's the answer but ultimately
we're going to wind up
um uh showing an assessor how this works
so hey and on call we work with defense
contractors just like you who have had
this dfar's nist itar and cmmc
compliance stuff dropped into the laps
like I see you on a sunny day baby we
teach you how to level up and be a
proper on-call compliance hero for your
company eliminating gaps great areas and
getting this solved all while showing
you how to leverage compliance is your
secret weapon so I have more Defense
work with higher profit margins now that
is what becoming an on-call compliance
hero can do for you if you're looking
for more help getting compliant our
compliance experts are always on call
for you visit cmmc compliance
secrets.com or check out the bio below
for links to get help right now if you
love the content we're putting out here
for you help us out with a big thumbs up
on that like button or even better smash
the Subscribe button to get the latest
compliance content as soon as our
compliance starts roll it out until next
compliance tip my friends stay safe and
secure out there and hit us in the
comments below to let us know what you'd
like to know more about when it comes to
information security and compliance I'll
see you on the next one
[Music]
thank you